WINNIE LAM: Hello everybody.
I'm Winne Lam.
It's surreal to be standing 10
feet away from the amazing race
car driver, Danica Patrick.
And I'm thrilled that
Claire Johnson is here
today to do the fireside
chat with Danica.
There are many women Googlers
who are in technical roles
where there are
more men than women.
So we thought it would
be inspiring to hear
Danica's story
about how she excels
in the male-dominated
field of race car driving.
So without further ado, please
help me give a very warm
welcome to Danica Patrick.
DANICA PATRICK: Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for coming.
We were just talking about
how sometimes people come,
sometimes people don't.
And I said that the
worst fear for someone
like me is that you do
these and nobody shows up.
Or you get introduced somewhere
and nobody knows who you are.
So thank you all for coming.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
I think my worst fear is
that I would host this
and no one would be here.
But you guys, nice job.
We filled the room.
I think we could've
used a bigger room.
So a couple things
because I know you all
want to hear from Danica.
Just so you know
about this talk.
I feel really pleased.
And I want to think Winnie
and Nicole and Rich.
And folks from the Google
GoDaddy team who helped
prep this.
We have some great slides and
photos and a couple of videos
to show.
And we also have a
bunch of questions
that luckily I was prepared
with to go through.
We probably aren't going to
have any time for any live Q&A.
But I have looked at the Dory.
So if you have stuff
on the Dory-- and Mave
is going to pass me notes--
Dory is our internal Q&A tool.
DANICA PATRICK: Got it.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: We're
all about the tech here.
DANICA PATRICK: OK.
I was like, I don't--
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: So people
can ask questions from there.
DANICA PATRICK:
--know who she is.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: She's like, I
have no idea what
you're talking about
but please don't bring it up.
But anyway, so we'll
keep an eye on the Dory.
But hopefully we'll get
to most of the topics
that you all have.
And in full disclosure,
I like to drive fast,
but I do not know that much
about race car driving.
DANICA PATRICK: Perfect.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: And some--
DANICA PATRICK: Neither do I.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: --of
the folks in the audience--
I think you know a
lot-- may not as well.
So I may follow up and ask
you to clarify a few things.
Don't you want to get out of
NASCAR and all the left turns
sometimes?
Go back to your
open wheel roots?
DANICA PATRICK: We have
a couple of road courses.
But what I notice in the
gym is that I'm definitely
dominant pushing with my right
and pulling with my left.
It's very out of balance
when I use dumbbells.
And they're independent.
And I'm like, yep.
And nope.
Can't get there.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: So
when you pick your gowns
for award shows would that
could be an issue for you?
DANICA PATRICK: Always.
Shoulders.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: We're good.
We're already getting into it.
So just so folks don't-- if you
don't know who Danica Patrick
is, I'm not sure why that is--
but she's the most searched
for athlete.
And we're a search company
among other things.
So certainly she's on our radar.
But has been an amazing
role model for women.
For girls.
But also for anyone who's
an aspiring race car driver.
And grew up in the sport.
And even went to
Europe for some time--
which her parents let
her do, which maybe we'll
ask how that went--
to continue her racing
education and practice.
And has driven with Indy car.
And is now with NASCAR
on the Sprint Cup Series
if I'm right about that.
DANICA PATRICK:
You got that right.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
And has been-- I
think folks know-- the GoDaddy
spokesperson for 13 years.
DANICA PATRICK:
Well, been in 13.
After this year, 13
Superbowl commercials.
But since 2007.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: Since 2007.
OK.
So just a lot of
Superbowl commercials.
DANICA PATRICK: A lot of
SuperBowl commercials.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: Since 2007.
And has also hosted the
Country Music Awards.
DANICA PATRICK: Yeah the
American Country Awards.
It was last month in Vegas.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: And been
on the cover of various hotshot
magazines.
We have one of them here.
Sports Illustrated
is one of them.
ESPN magazine, right?
I think saw that one.
Anyway, so she-- And you
have your own company, right?
"Danica Racing."
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
You're a businesswoman.
DANICA PATRICK: I
write President on it.
So it makes me feel really
cool when they say title.
Your signature and title.
And I write president.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: Or
if you go through customs
and they say, what's your job?
DANICA PATRICK: I
don't actually know
what to write when it comes
to that point in time.
I write the same thing now.
But for a long time I didn't
know what to write for my job.
Driver?
Or race car driver?
Or professional driver?
Automotive driver?
President?
I mean, that would help.
I would think.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
I think race car driver
might be cooler than president.
DANICA PATRICK: I
write race car driver.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: I
think-- I'm down with that.
DANICA PATRICK: Wow, you think
that's cooler than president?
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: I do.
Danica Patrick: Well, it's
probably a lot easier.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: That
might be the state of politics
these days.
All right.
Anyway.
Let's talk a little
bit about when
you knew that this was
a passion of yours.
DANICA PATRICK: Well, I
started racing go-karts
when I was 10 years old.
And it really was because
my sister wanted to race.
There I am.
Adorable.
Yup.
I still need glasses,
but I wear contacts.
And I'm positively blind.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: And
your sister was younger?
DANICA PATRICK: My
sister was eight
and I was 10 years old, which
is why my number was 10.
So it was really just something
to do together as a family.
And I just took to it.
I started winning my first year.
And I won the championship.
But this kid blocked
me and I didn't
know how to get around
because he drove down
the inside of the straightaway.
I figured it out after that.
You just push him off
the end of the track.
But I didn't know then.
But I think really it
came from the first year.
And just being successful.
And I really liked
practicing and getting
better and seeing improvement.
And I mean, we all tend to
like things that we're good at.
And it was something that went
well pretty quickly for me.
So it was really year one.
I thought I would go to
college for engineering.
But I didn't.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
We support that.
We like that.
DANICA PATRICK: I
ended up going--
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: We
all support the driving.
DANICA PATRICK: I ended
up going to England.
And I'm not sure
which one was harder.
Which one would have
been harder, England
or engineering college?
But I wanted to go to
college for engineering
so I could know how
to work on my car.
But I went to a different
kind of college ultimately.
But those were my
plans at 10 years old.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: So how old
were you when you
went to England?
DANICA PATRICK: I was 16.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: Wow
and so your family said--
DANICA PATRICK: Yeah I was
a junior in high school.
And I wasn't really even
there very much junior year.
I went over to England
in the first semester.
I went over for two of
the four months of school.
And did a little bit of racing.
And then I went back
full time after that.
So I left high school halfway
through my junior year.
And I've never looked back.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
And was the thinking
on that, that you would just
get more experience and--
DANICA PATRICK: Yeah.
It was described to me
that I can learn more there
in one year than five
years in America.
And the opportunity
was there to do it.
Really what ended up
happening was this person--
that told me that I could learn
more there than in the states--
had followed my career
then for a couple of years.
And contacted me
when I turned 16.
And said, we've
been watching you.
We want to help
you in your career.
And that's when I went over
to England for a little while
to check things out.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: This is
someone in the British racing
scene?
DANICA PATRICK: There
was an Englishman.
And then there was
a Texas-based family
that had been involved in
racing for a long time.
So they had followed my
career for a couple of years.
And fortunately
saw me win a lot.
And after that I
moved to England.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: That's great.
So we have gotten
a few questions
on our moderator tool.
And certainly, as
Winnie mentioned,
our Women at Google group
is interested in-- as you
were coming up through the sport
and in those earlier years,
I'm sure it still
is the case today,
but you're a little bit
more established now.
You were certainly
contending with the fact
that it was more of a
male-dominated sport.
Although women, I think
as I understand it,
from the history of NASCAR were
allowed to race since 1949.
Not the case for
the IndyCar races.
But anyway, women
were allowed to race
and there were some
women who raced.
But it just really, as
this happens sometimes
in engineering
classes, very few.
And for you, you've become
arguably the most famous
female race car driver.
How was it coming up
through the sport?
Did you find that there
were overt obstacles?
Or was it just
occasionally an issue?
DANICA PATRICK: I think that the
big difference between me, when
I came along versus when
some of the women in the past
in the earlier years, were there
is that-- take for instance
my first Indy 500 was 2005.
And you had to do something
called rookie orientation,
which meant you had
to go out and do 190
for five laps or 10 laps.
And then you had to do 200.
And then you do 210.
And then 220.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: That
would be miles per hour?
DANICA PATRICK: Yes.
And so it was just a
build up in the process.
And so I would come
in from making a run--
and once you've passed
your test and gone
through all those speeds, then
you get to practice basically.
And I'd come in and I was
basically the quickest car.
So I would come into
the pits and everybody
would be cheering.
There was a huge slew of
photographers and journalists
in front of my car.
And on the pit
wall there was tons
of fans behind the
behind the fence.
And I was embraced in general.
I'm sure there's still haters.
But they exist always.
In everything.
There's always
going to be people
that don't like you
or believe in you.
But in general, very well
received and embraced.
And I think that's
a big difference.
In the past I don't think
that was there for them.
Everyone has to
prove themselves.
There's no doubt about that.
I face it as a rookie.
I face it as a girl.
And I face it as
just a competitor.
As a person trying
to beat other people.
So it's always a
challenge to earn respect.
But I think that there's
probably a few more doubters
along the way.
Or it may take a few
extra times of proving
what you do, what you can
do, before people really
believe it.
And then of course there's
just some that never do.
But it's a process.
And still going on.
And I'm sure it will for awhile.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: And
talking about the Indy 500,
you were the first woman-- you
lead for 19 laps in the Indy
500 when you were 23 years old.
So did you feel like you
proved it at that point?
DANICA PATRICK: Well,
I think that when
I got my ride in IndyCar-- It
came the year before at Indy.
And I had gone to a press
conference at the track.
And I wasn't racing.
But the team that I drove
for in the lower level racing
had an IndyCar team.
And so I went to a press
conference on Thursday
before the race.
And all of a sudden
my boss said,
and Danica's going to drive
in IndyCars next year.
And I was like, I mean,
I'm not going to argue,
but I didn't know you
were going to say that.
So it came pretty suddenly.
But I got into it in my first
year of Indy Car and thought,
it's not a for sure thing.
You still have to do it.
Just getting there is not there.
You need to do some good
things and establish yourself.
And get some roots in the sport.
And have proper
support from sponsors.
And after that Indy 500 I did.
There was a certain level I
felt a little better after that.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
I mean you clearly
had earned your way.
DANICA PATRICK: It was
definitely a pivotal year.
And it was a magical month.
And it was full
of highs and lows.
And the lows were really just
that I was running out energy
to do interviews.
But that's a good
problem to have.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
Luckily we're catching her
at the beginning before
the season starts.
DANICA PATRICK: This is my
first day at work, everyone,
this year.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: That's
true for a lot of us as well.
DANICA PATRICK: Is it?
OK.
Well, welcome back.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
On the holidays.
DANICA PATRICK: High on
sugar from the holidays?
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: Exactly.
So, then, you won the
IndyCar race in Japan.
And did that feel like--
how big a deal was that?
Or was it not a big deal?
Because you already kind
of made it in IndyCar.
DANICA PATRICK: Well,
I mean it's something
that I am-- I even said it
back then in 2008-- that it
felt long overdue for me.
There were opportunities that
were probably even better
to win along the way
that didn't happen.
Versus that day.
So it was but there was
somebody-- another driver told
me that year at some point,
he said, you know what?
One day you're going to be doing
just the same thing that you've
been doing every day
and you're going to win.
And that's exactly
what happened.
You're doing the same thing
that you do every day.
And so it was a
feeling of relief.
And for the casual fan
or the casual consumer,
first place and winning is
very easy to understand.
And so it was nice
from that perspective.
And there was a lot of talk
and argumentative points
about I haven't won.
And so it did take care of that.
And of course eventually--
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
It checked off that box.
DANICA PATRICK: So,
I mean, I wanted
to win a lot more than that.
And there were opportunities.
But it seemed like my talent
as a driver in IndyCar
was going like this and
my cars went like this.
So that didn't really
interject at the right point.
But they did kind
of right at 2008.
Your equipment is
really important too.
very important.
It's the chicken before the egg.
What is it?
Is it the driver?
Or is it the car?
Well, you really can't
have one without the other.
So if things aren't where
they need to be there
then the best
driver can't take--
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: We kind of
have that with computing power.
DANICA PATRICK: Sure.
Absolutely.
You're only as good
as your resources.
Your technology.
Your coworkers.
Your brainstorming.
Your motherboard?
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
Yeah, exactly.
Your core.
Your chip core.
DANICA PATRICK: Yeah, that's it.
Chip it up.
Chip me up.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
That's what I'm saying.
Back to the
male-dominated thing.
I have found-- and I think
some of the female engineers,
hopefully some of them are
in the room-- sometimes
the situation is you
don't get the respect.
And you talked a
little bit about that.
And then you earn it.
And maybe it takes
little bit longer.
And the other situation is maybe
you get too much attention.
Where you're just a
person doing a job.
And I think for you it's
probably frustrating.
I mean, you've gotten
a lot of attention.
I think as a driver.
But maybe a little bit more
sometimes as a female race
car-- and particularly
being the first woman
to do some of the things--
we're going to talk about a few
of them as well.
DANICA PATRICK: And
that does happen.
It's a double-edged sword.
When you are different or
outside of the box and people
are paying attention.
You do something good or kind
of good and people realize it.
You do something
bad or kind of bad
and people realize that, too.
So it's a double-edged sword.
But I mean, I'll take it.
Because there's times where
I finished fourth and it
makes big news.
And that doesn't
happen for anyone else.
So they're noticing
the little things
along the way a little bit more.
What happened in my first year.
Or something like that.
Something a little bit
unique about it sticks out.
And because I'm a
girl and I'm different
and these things haven't
been done before.
All I know is that in my
career I just work really hard.
And I know that when I've
done everything possible
on and off the track to
perform, then people's opinions
or judgments can't affect me.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
When you work hard,
you've got a lot of, I
think, physical conditioning
you probably have to do.
And then, do you just
have to drive a lot?
DANICA PATRICK: For my
physical conditioning?
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: For both.
I mean, how do
you stay in shape?
Danica Patrick: I mean, I
take it to the streets--
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
For driving 200mph.
DANICA PATRICK: In a
calculated fashion.
I do make a lot of
people mad on the road.
I'm sorry about that.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: I meant more
in a contained environment.
DANICA PATRICK: No I mean I'm--
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: On the track.
Do you go and drive every day?
DANICA PATRICK: There's testing.
Practice.
Or whatever you want to call it.
We call it testing.
This week-- this
Thursday and Friday--
we'll be at Daytona getting
ready for the Daytona 500
at the end of March.
So you do some of that.
The real conditioning
comes in the season when
you get in the car and you get
racing every single weekend.
And we have two weekends
out of-- we have 38 races
and two weekends off.
So we race all year.
I mean it just feels
like we race all year.
And then we get five
minutes off and then
you're right back at it again.
So it goes pretty hard.
For sure.
But do you have to be the
fittest person in the world
to drive a race car?
No.
But you do you have to be fit.
You do have to be race
fit, as we call it.
There's a lot of repetition.
There's a lot of heat.
There's a lot of adrenaline.
And it's about being able to
control all that and keep cool.
And literally keep cool.
And keep cool in your head.
And not grip the wheel so hard.
And be conditioned for
the repetition, too.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
And the repetition
meaning-- because you
don't want to zone out.
Cause you got to keep--
DANICA PATRICK: Well, it's
this and this and this and this
and this--- so it's when the
car is not balanced right.
It's not just a matter
of turning the wheel.
It's a matter of
turning the wheel
and feeling what it's doing.
And catching it all the
way around the corner.
So you're tensed
up the whole time.
And then even down
the straightaway
the car wants to turn left.
It has stagger.
It wants to turn left.
So you still have to hold
it down the straightaway.
But in the corner you
release and let it in.
And then you're just chasing
it through the corner.
Or you're adding a whole bunch
of wheel because it won't turn
and then your shoulder
gets an impingement.
And that's not good either.
I know.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: And by
the way, speaking of the heat,
I'm all worried because
the room is a little warm.
She's looking at me like--
DANICA PATRICK: No,
those cars are probably
130 degrees inside
the whole time.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
So you must sweat off
10 pounds riding it.
DANICA PATRICK:
It's really awesome.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: But
then you eat one Big Mac.
DANICA PATRICK:
Before we started,
we were just talking about
holidays and being in shape.
And I said that by nature
that my job is athletic.
And if not, I just sweat it off.
By the end of the season I'm
always my fittest and leanest.
Because every weekend
you're in the car three days
a week minimum.
I was in the car.
I tested on average every
other week for two days.
Every other week, I
would say, on average.
So I'm in the car almost five
days a week most of the time.
And then the races
are four hours long.
So the pit stop isn't
like a pit stop down
the road for a candy
bar and an energy drink.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: No smoothie.
No Starbucks.
DANICA PATRICK: I do drink
something with calories
but it's not--
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: Like
those gel things or whatever?
DANICA PATRICK: No, it's
like a premix shake stuff.
But it's by no means a meal.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
Well, speaking
of doing a ton of
racing, we we wanted
to show a video-- Oh, look.
And there you are
winning, as you win a lot.
But one of the videos
we wanted to show--
it's kind of a long
video guys, but it
was an exciting, historic
event which was-- she's
the first woman to
win the pole position.
And this is at the Daytona 500.
So we're going to watch that
video for a couple minutes
and then we'll talk about it.
DANICA PATRICK: That happens
the week before the race.
So when's the race?
The Daytona 500 is usually
the third or fourth.
February 23 this year?
So it'll be the week
before that on Saturday.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: All right.
So in about a month or so.
You're just doing a job there.
But are you thinking, I'm
making history right now?
Are you thinking, I just
need to get pole position?
What was your--
DANICA PATRICK: I mean, I'm just
thinking about taking the car
and taking it to
its potential level.
And not wasting its potential
by making a little mistake
and missing a shift.
Getting up to speed.
Or clipping the apron when
you're going around the corner.
Because the car doesn't
just go just dead straight.
It kind of follows the road.
And it pulls.
And it moves.
So it's not hard.
Daytona's not the hardest
track at all to drive.
But just the little things.
I'm not going to be able
to take the car at Daytona
and take it from a 15th
place car to a pole car.
But I can screw it up and
lose the pole for sure
by making little
mistakes on the track.
By not getting up
to speed right.
Not taking the right line.
As in, letting the car
open up and pick up speed.
Because every time
you hold wheel on it,
it's going to scrub
speed and slow it down.
But you also want the
shortest distance.
So there's a little
marriage between letting
it open up off the corner
to build up momentum,
but also running
a short distance
so that you're not adding
feet onto your lap.
Making a longer lap.
So just little things like that.
And catching the apron.
You're trying to be as low
as you can on the corner.
But the track has
a transition point.
And at that transition point,
if the car bottoms out,
the body work will hit it
and scrub a bunch of speed
off the car.
So just little things like that.
But I'm not really
thinking about history.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
Basically your answer is
you're doing your job.
DANICA PATRICK: Yeah,
I'm doing my job.
Absolutely.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
You're looking
to win is what you're doing.
DANICA PATRICK: Yes, exactly.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
That's a good answer.
DANICA PATRICK:
Watching qualifying
is painful as a driver.
After you go there's
literally nothing else
that you can do
to make it better.
It could only get worse.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: And
you need to hang around there
and watch it, or?
DANICA PATRICK: I went
and worked out actually.
I was like, what do I do?
And I just I went
back to the bus,
got my gym clothes on,
and went into the gym
and worked out and
watched qualifying.
I was still in the gym when
the last cars were qualifying.
And my PR people kept
coming in and saying,
you need to get ready.
You need to get ready.
You're going to be on pole.
I'm like, I'm not getting
out of these clothes
until I see that
car pass the line
and I know I'm on the pole.
Because I'm not jinxing this.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: Good for you.
DANICA PATRICK: I
forgot to eat then, too.
So me with no food is no good.
It's no good.
Any girls in here
that feel me on that?
Seems to be more
of a girl issue.
So I didn't eat lunch because
I went and worked out.
And then I had to go do all the
interviews for hours and hours
afterwards.
I probably kept Brian
Williams waiting,
but I had to eat a sandwich
at some point in time.
But it was exciting.
It was a lot of fun.
And it was really
neat to see number
10 at the top of the boards.
And it's cool just to have
number 10 back really.
Because it was my go-kart
number, as you guys saw.
So I got to choose that number.
So it's really neat to
have my old number back.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
When you went to NASCAR
you got to choose?
DANICA PATRICK: When I went to
Stewart-Haas Racing and Sprint
Cup I got to choose my number.
Yeah.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: That's great.
That's a factoid for us.
That's good.
So you are one of
the only 13 drivers
who has led laps in both the
Indy 500 and the Daytona 500.
DANICA PATRICK: So I
think that's probably
the coolest statistic to me.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: Is it?
I wanted to ask you about.
Is that-- again remembering
I don't know that
much about race car driving--
so is that just totally
different kinds of racing?
And to be at the top of
your game in both of them
is pretty amazing?
DANICA PATRICK: I mean, they
both have the same elements.
But they're just newly
learned disciplines.
So I don't know
how to relate it.
It's like a whole
new computer system.
It's like, all right.
I need to figure this out.
But it's all the same--
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
Different programming language.
DANICA PATRICK: --sort of ideas.
It's just trying to figure
it out all over again.
And you'll get it.
But it just takes a
little bit of time.
And so it's the same thing.
So, yeah.
I thought that's the
coolest statistic.
To be one of 13
drivers in history
that have led Daytona and Indy.
That's pretty neat.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: And
why are those two races
such a big deal?
I mean as you said--
DANICA PATRICK:
They're the oldest.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
--the Daytona track--
DANICA PATRICK: They're
some of the oldest.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: The oldest.
Got it.
DANICA PATRICK: Indy's
about 100 years old.
And Daytona's
about 50 years old.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: And
they get great TV coverage
and all that stuff.
DANICA PATRICK: They do.
There's a lot that
goes around them.
Qualifying is the weekend
before for both of them.
So qualifying happens.
There's a lot of
media around that.
And then it goes all
the way through the week
into the race weekend.
Yeah.
They generally have
a culture of fun.
I mean, there's a
lot of campsites.
And people that hang out.
And bonfire.
And set up tiki bars.
And play cornhole.
And fly their Dale Jr flags.
And some of them
have Danica flags.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: We
need to get more Danica flags.
So let's talk a little
bit about things
that are related to what you do.
Teamwork.
Advice you might have.
Dealing with criticism.
And one of things you've
already talked about--
and I think people
here might relate
is-- sometimes it feels like
you've got this repetitive
stuff and you've
got to stay focused.
And you're also dealing with a
lot of scrutiny, as you said.
Maybe a little bit
more being a woman.
What advice would
you have to people
who are facing obstacles?
Who need to maintain their
focus and their confidence.
Even when day in
and day out they
may not be getting
the rewards that they
are hoping to get for
their work product.
DANICA PATRICK: I mean, I think
the difference between someone
who ultimately is successful
and someone who isn't, is just
getting up and trying again.
And I feel like I've
seen that in my life--
again, to other people--
is that things get hard
and people try again.
And things got hard and people
might try again, might not.
And then things got hard and
they just don't try again.
And giving up
can't be an option.
And I think that goes back
to the core of making sure
that whatever it is
you're doing is something
that you love to do.
Something that you enjoy.
Something that maybe if
you didn't even get paid,
would you still do it?
And I think that's what
pulls you through those times
ultimately.
And that's what keeps
you coming back for more.
And that's what that
passion and that love
for what it is that you do
is what keeps you going.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: So would you
say your resilience
and that persistence
is because you love
what you do so much?
Or is there something
about your parents?
Or anything in your upbringing?
DANICA PATRICK: I
think that genetically
I'm determined
because my dad was
very much like that for sure.
Very persistent and determined.
But I think it's also
because I found something
that I love to do.
And there's plenty
of other stuff
that I've done that
I didn't keep doing.
I mean, I didn't keep
playing basketball.
Let's face it.
But I kept racing.
So it was about finding that.
I feel.
And finding it really young.
I'm very fortunate that
I found it really young.
And I tell everyone,
young or old,
if you could do anything in
the world, what would you do?
Well, why can't
you do that, then?
At least start.
At least just try to make
an effort at doing it.
You're not going to get
there within one shot.
But you just need
to take baby steps.
And opportunities along the way.
And I feel like, especially
people get out of college
and they have this idea
of what they want to do
and their holding out
until they get it.
Just get going.
Just get working.
And get the experience.
And start working
your way there.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: I
think that's great advice.
So you said what makes you
different makes you great.
Where does that
advice come from?
When you talk to people.
DANICA PATRICK:
Well, I mean I think
that the most obvious
one, really obviously,
is being a girl.
So when I was
younger, and living
in England and
early teen years, I
didn't care that I was a girl.
I just didn't want to
make it real obvious.
I mean, I didn't
want it to stand out.
I didn't wear nail
polish because when
I talk about the race
car I didn't want guys
looking at my hands and
seeing pink fingernails.
I didn't wear pink
and purple and make
it really flashy and obvious.
No hearts and bows.
And just wanted to blend in.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
You're describing
my seven-year-old daughter.
DANICA PATRICK: Am I really?
Hearts and bows?
Or didn't want to
wear hearts and bows?
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
She's now rejecting them.
But she was all in them.
DANICA PATRICK: Well, you go
through these phases where you
feel comfortable and
sometimes you don't.
And I didn't really feel
comfortable making it obvious.
And so it really was--
I came back from England
when I was 19.
And I let myself go there
to be a girl a little bit.
And it really came
from a racy photo shoot
that I did that it
was more girly of me.
And it just all of a sudden--
stuff started happening.
And people were contacting me.
And sponsors and teams.
But nobody questioned
what I could do.
It wasn't like people
didn't think I could race.
Or their opinion
really changed on that.
Maybe they had an
opinion on what I did.
But it didn't change
the opportunity
to be able to do
what I wanted to do.
It just really was
opening doors and it
was allowing-- it was me being
able to tap into something
that was part of my personality.
I mean, I think we're not
one-dimensional people.
We have all kinds of
different sides to us.
I don't just race.
I don't just work on cars.
I race.
And I like to cook.
And I like to travel.
And I like to look pretty.
And I like to get dressed up.
And I like hair and makeup.
And I like all
those other things.
So it was a way for me to--
it was an extension of me.
But it was celebrated.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: So success
came to you as you
embraced who you were.
DANICA PATRICK: Exactly.
So, sometimes, I really
feel that whatever
it is that's the
most different about
you is probably
the most important.
And the most special.
And the most useful.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: I once had
a boss who-- we
worked in consulting
and we'd go and talk to
clients and I was usually
the only woman in the room.
And he said, whenever
you say something,
everyone is going
to be listening.
Because you're different than
everyone else in the room.
And I was like, yeah.
And I think you're
right on there.
I like it.
So let's talk about the team.
You mentioned this a little bit.
You've got a whole
team you work with.
You've also got the car and
the technology of the car.
How important is that
team for your success?
And how do you work with them?
What's your role in the team?
DANICA PATRICK: I mean,
the team is critical.
Obviously.
I mean, you need a bus driver.
You got to get a truck
driver to get the car there.
You've got to get guys to
put the tires on, of course.
So there's a whole bunch
of steps in the process.
And it can't happen
without the other.
But I think more importantly
with team, for me,
is about morale.
It's about attitude.
It's about your mood and
keeping everyone in a good mood.
All those guys that
you see right there,
we see each other every
weekend of the year.
Pretty much.
And so that can wear on you.
And it can get exhausting.
That's the family vacation.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
There's your family.
But you had that whole team
of guys behind the car.
DANICA PATRICK: Yeah.
So that's my crew
chief on the left.
He's kind of the other
co-team leader with me.
But the two of us dictate
the mood of the entire team.
Being a leader is also
being a cheerleader.
And it's very important.
So I think that team
is a lot attitude.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: And then
is your family with you a lot?
We saw them all on the plane.
DANICA PATRICK: Yeah, yeah.
That was the day after
the season ended.
We went on vacation.
So that's Ricky's family.
And my family.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
Did they go out
for all those 38 weekends?
DANICA PATRICK: They go out
for-- between the two families,
we see them quite a bit.
And we have two buses.
So our family will
stay on my bus
or his family will
stay on my bus.
And we'll stay on Ricky's bus.
And we have a total
fancy campground.
We just open our
buses up together.
Open up the tents.
We've got picnic tables.
Grills.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
You're making me want a bus.
DANICA PATRICK: Family's
really important.
And I think that as an
extension of your mood,
family plays a role in that too.
If your home life isn't good
that tends to bleed over.
And vice versa.
So keeping everything
in order and being happy
is really important,
I think, for success.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
You talked a little bit--
I think that's great and it
seems like having that support
system--
DANICA PATRICK: I think I
gotta cheer for the Colts.
We were at a Colts game.
I mean, I'm a Bears fan.
But I don't know anymore.
We haven't been doing so well.
The Colts are on their way.
Did anyone see them come back?
28 points.
Down a half.
That was pretty impressive.
I don't know if they'd beat
a California team or not.
But I'm sorry but--
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: We
have to get off this topic.
DANICA PATRICK: But
I did watch the game.
But I'm still a girl.
I still don't always remember
all the details about it.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
Me either, but I like it.
DANICA PATRICK: I do too.
I love football.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
All right.
So talking about-- not
related to the NFL--
DANICA PATRICK: Anybody watch
the GoDaddy Bowl last night?
Maybe next year.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: But
you went from NFL to college.
You just confused
me for a second.
DANICA PATRICK: I did.
I did.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
But that was actually
a good segue for what I needed.
Sponsorship and brand building.
So let's talk about it.
It's an interesting
thing for you.
You're a brand.
You've got Danica Racing.
You've got your name
as basically a brand.
You've got your
sponsorship relationship
with GoDaddy and
some other companies.
But did you ever actively
think about-- I mean,
you almost mentioned
this when you
talked about the
photo-shoot and how
things started to
happen for you.
Do you ever think, I'm
building a brand here?
When did you realize that?
Or when did you start
to think that way?
DANICA PATRICK: It
took a while for sure.
I mean, I think that
the idea of brand
and the idea of role model
took a little while to set in.
Because it all seems so new.
I'm like, I don't know.
I'm just driving.
And I'm trying to
figure myself out.
But I've been really
fortunate in my career.
I've had great
sponsors along the way.
And Go Daddy being the best.
Where I can be myself.
They stand behind
me no matter what.
And they have great core values.
And they've done some really
great stuff and continue to.
And so brand is very important.
In this day and age,
especially with social media
and everything like
that, we're all
reading through authenticity
pretty quickly and easily.
I think you can tell what's
real and what's not real.
And if there's anything that
I want to do, it's be real.
And be someone
that you can trust.
And someone that you
look at what I'm doing
and you believe in it.
And so I've been
lucky enough to be
able to be selective over
the years with my partners.
And I've got great ones.
And they're extensions
of who I am.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: Are
there are other things that
come to your mind when
you think about what
you hope everyone relate--
DANICA PATRICK: Other than fast?
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: Fast.
Good one.
DANICA PATRICK:
Well, back in 2009,
I signed on with IMG, which
is now William Morris.
But we created a brand statement
or a brand title for me.
And it was Beautiful Revolution.
And it was really
just about being
able to be feminine, be who
you are, but yet be different.
And so that's the
statement from my--
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
And be revolutionary.
And were you an
active participant
in that whole process?
DANICA PATRICK: Absolutely.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
That's pretty cool.
DANICA PATRICK: There was all
these storyboards going on.
And photos of me
doing certain things.
Categorized stuff
from the internet.
And it built a story of
what really stands out
about me in the public eye.
And what people are
paying attention to.
And then words start
to get developed
from those storyboards
and from those collages.
And then it keeps
whittling down to a title.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: Wow.
Cool.
So I think we have
a picture of you
at the Country Music Awards or--
DANICA PATRICK: The
American Country Awards.
Oh my gosh.
That's the best shot I've
seen of the height difference.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
If we have time--
DANICA PATRICK: I have boots on.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
If we have time
later we'll show a
funny video from this.
But we're going to
run short on time.
But I wanted to ask you about
when you do stuff like this.
When you make these choices.
Besides they don't let you
choose your co-host, I guess.
Or your co-presenter.
DANICA PATRICK:
No, he was great.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: He's so tall.
DANICA PATRICK: Chris is great.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: Do
you think about your brand?
Do you think about
what's fun for you?
Or whether you have
time in your schedule?
DANICA PATRICK: Absolutely.
I think about
things that are fun.
I don't know--
Does anybody listen
to country music in here?
Not many.
I'm not surprised.
We're in California.
It's OK.
But I know there's
some of you out there.
So it was one of those
things-- country music
it just happened for me.
I never, ever listened to it.
And my dad always
said, it feels like I'm
kissing a horse when I
listen to this stuff.
So my upbringing, which
I feel like dictates
who we are-- seeing your parents
and seeing the way you grew up
is an explanation
and not an excuse.
You are who you are
because of your family.
And my dad hated country music.
So I never listened to it.
And so I got to NASCAR.
And I mean GAC.
GAC is on the TV.
And it's all country
bumpkin music.
And I just wasn't
having any of it.
I did a music video
with Miranda Lambert.
And it was called
"Fastest Girl in Town."
And I had not heard her song.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
She seems pretty cool.
DANICA PATRICK:
She is very cool.
But I hadn't heard her song.
And it was already
out on the radio.
So I felt kind of bad.
So I thought, I'll
get her albums.
And she had just started a
new band with two other girls.
And they're called
the Pistol Annies.
So I got that too.
And I listened to them.
And I was like, I think
I like country music.
And it just happened like that.
Now it's pretty much
all I listen to.
So when the American
Country Awards
asked me to co-host
the show, I'm like,
you mean present, right?
No, co-host.
OK.
So--
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
That's a lot of work.
DANICA PATRICK: It was
a huge undertaking.
And I'm extremely decisive.
You don't have to ask twice.
You might have to
tell me something
twice because I forget.
But you don't have to
ask a question twice.
And my agent asked me
if I wanted to do it.
And he's like,
this is a big deal.
This is a definite yes.
And I'm like, I'm going
to need to call you back.
And in the past he would
tell me, call me back
and let me know.
And I would say, Alan, the
only thing I'm going to do
is forget to call you back.
I already know the answer.
And so I told him,
I think I'm going
to need to call you
back on this one.
And I asked around about
what people thought.
Basically, did anybody
think I could handle this?
So I said yes and it was--
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: Because
that's like multiple hours
being up on that stage.
DANICA PATRICK: It's
a shorter country
show but it's two hours.
And you're co-hosting.
So it's important.
And I ended up singing
and dancing on the show.
I wore a showgirl outfit
at one point in time.
You should have seen the number
they wanted me to wear first.
I tempered it to
feel comfortable.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: Good for you.
DANICA PATRICK: Because you've
got to feel comfortable.
And of course that's
the photo that
makes the magazine or newspaper.
But it went great.
It was a lot of fun.
And more than anything, it was
about having an experience.
And growing as a person.
And doing something
outside of my comfort zone.
I'm much more comfortable
answering questions
than I am reading a
prompter and having
to do something pre-programmed.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: Back
to the advice and we'll close.
And we'll talk a little
bit about internet
and small businesses and things.
You really stretched
yourself, right?
You did something you weren't
that comfortable doing.
Where do you--
DANICA PATRICK: I mean, I've
always wanted to be a singer,
but I'm not.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
But you sang on the show.
DANICA PATRICK: I sang a lot.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
Where does that come from?
I mean, if you're talking
to people in the room
here who are thinking
of trying something new
or doing something different.
DANICA PATRICK: I mean, I think
that's the only way you grow.
And that's the only
way you can start
to learn your real capabilities.
And what I've learned
over the years with me,
is that trying new things ends
up usually going pretty well.
And that's where
you start to get
more confidence in yourself.
And if anything, you
just learn something.
And you have an experience.
And life is about experiences.
And if something exciting
comes your way just say yes.
Just try something new.
And not be afraid.
And the worst thing
you do is fail.
And you just don't
do it anymore.
Or you try again.
So new experiences
are how you grow.
And I think that, that goes
back to the core of-- even
just living in a new
country when I was 16.
I grew up so fast
because I did that.
And it's about doing things
that are outside of your comfort
zone.
Something you would not do.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: That's great.
So speaking of about building
businesses and brands
and doing some new things.
One of things that
is not new for you
is your relationship
with GoDaddy.
But we're going to
talk a little bit
about the commercial this year.
And the internet and
small businesses.
In your own brand building
and business building,
how important has
the internet been?
You mentioned social media.
You mentioned
people really being
able to smell whether
something's authentic or not.
Do you use any Google products?
Do you use technology a lot?
DANICA PATRICK: I google myself.
Is that bad?
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
No, that's not bad.
DANICA PATRICK: I actually
google my name and Ricky's name
and I look for new photos of us.
Because we get candid
ones taken at the track.
And I never see them.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: I
do not have pictures of me
and my husband on the
internet when I google.
DANICA PATRICK: I will say that
Google is the only thing I ever
use for search engine.
Always.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: Oh,
we're very happy to hear that.
Thank you.
OK.
That was a shameless
Google question.
DANICA PATRICK:
That's the truth.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: Do you
think about building businesses
online or the work that GoDaddy
does with small businesses?
How do you think about that?
Or are you separate
from their business?
DANICA PATRICK: Where I came
from-- I mean my first Indy
500 in 2005.
My website shut down because
there was too much traffic.
It couldn't handle it.
I don't know.
The server wasn't big enough.
We didn't see that coming.
So--
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: So
that taught you a lesson.
DANICA PATRICK: It taught
me a lesson in 2005
about being prepared.
But also about how much
interest there is there.
And like you said,
I'm usually one
of the more searched athletes.
And so internet is a huge source
of how we learn about things.
How we maybe choose to
cheer for something.
Choose to like something.
I mean, I use it all
the time for everything.
I mean, GoDaddy is all
about small businesses.
And for me that
taps right into me.
I mean, I'm finding
new gyms to go
to because I'm
always on the road.
A restaurant.
A store.
You name it.
A hotel.
I need locations.
I need hours.
And if you're not on the
internet, I can't find you.
So I use the
internet constantly.
And it's been a
source of how I've
gotten to where I am today.
And it can also be a
source for someone else
to see their dreams
come true, too,
by making themselves relative.
I feel like if you're
not on the internet,
you're not relevant
in this day and age.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: We agree.
Thank you for saying that.
We'd love to see more
businesses get online.
And we're thrilled that GoDaddy
does so much work to help them.
When you think about your
relationship with GoDaddy--
I mean you've been in the
most Superbowl commercials
of any celebrity or
some stat like that.
Which is kind of wild.
But think about it.
DANICA PATRICK: It
is kind of weird.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: And
that's since 2007, right?
DANICA PATRICK: It's like 100
million people every time.
That's crazy.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: That's a lot.
That's a lot of eyeballs.
A lot of impressions.
Then you've got
the YouTube people
watching it all over again,
which we see a lot of.
When you think about how
their advertising has evolved
and what they're planning
now for this year--
I don't know how much you're
allowed to talk about it--
but you've grown up together.
Do you work together on
the creative concepts?
Or do you do show up and
they're like, here's the plan.
How does it work?
DANICA PATRICK:
A little of both.
But there's always that trump
card of, I don't like that.
There always has been.
We both respect each other.
And so it's been a
great relationship
from the very beginning.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: So anything
you could tell us
about this year's ad?
DANICA PATRICK: No, not really.
I mean, I think there was some
photos that got out there.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
I heard it's different.
DANICA PATRICK: Yeah,
there's two of them.
I'm in one of them.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: And they're
talking about
getting found online.
I've been told that much.
DANICA PATRICK: Yeah.
Well, it's all about that.
And it's definitely
about showing women now
in a really powerful way of
being small business owners.
Being confident.
And trying to see
their dreams come true.
And so I like that.
I mean, I completely
relate to that.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
Do think of yourself
as a small business owner?
DANICA PATRICK: I mean,
I guess I do more so now.
I think about it.
And I think about it in
the long-term of like,
at some point in time I
won't be racing anymore.
And then what am I going to do?
So building the brand
up to a certain point
and then maybe
branching off so that
when I retire from
racing-- I'm probably
not going to be
65-- I'll still have
something fun to do
outside of racing.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: Do you have
advice for women in business?
When you think about
yourself as a business woman
or your future-- you've given
a lot of great advice actually
this whole talk-- but when you
think about the business side
of it--
DANICA PATRICK: I mean, I think
that first and foremost, it's
making sure that it is
something that you love doing.
But then it's about confidence.
I mean, I remember
being a kid and going
into a business meeting.
And I said a lot of I
thinks and maybes and likes.
And it's about being
poignant, confident.
You want this.
This is what's going to happen.
And being aggressive
with your words.
And I think that that's
something to always keep
in mind-- is to
just be confident
through the whole process.
And the way that at least
I've generated confidence,
is by doing my homework and
being smart about something.
And knowledge is power.
And those old
commercials when I was
a kid watching Sunday morning
cartoons-- knowledge is power
and stars flew
across the screen.
It's true.
You can't be in full
control and know everything
and do a good job unless
you really do your homework
and know what you're asking for.
What you're trying
to accomplish.
So confidence and
doing your homework.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
You sound like you're
someone who works a lot
on being well-prepared.
I mean you must have prepared
for this thing a lot.
DANICA PATRICK: OK.
Quick little story.
So I got there to
Vegas and it was
like four or five
days before the show.
I didn't have anything yet.
I saw the opening.
The cold opening was a pre-tape.
And I had seen that.
But I saw nothing else.
So it's just how it works.
Because the writers that do
all the shows-- the writers
they do all the shows.
So they came off of
a show that had just
aired a couple weeks earlier.
And then they started
writing the ACA's.
So it was like, you don't
really have content.
So it kind of scared me.
So it wasn't until we went
into our first rehearsal was
on-- the show was on
Tuesday-- Saturday
we went and read prompter and
did blocks or whatever it is.
And we read the script
on the prompter.
I had never seen the script.
And I'm reading it on prompter
for the very first time.
And so it was a mild disaster.
And so, I mean, words
like, a bad rehearsal
is a good sign for a good
show, they were telling me.
And I'm like, shoot.
So it was a whole
new experience.
It was like cramming for a test.
As if I ever did that.
But it was solid Saturday,
Sunday, Monday, Tuesday of line
reads and going over things.
I mean, I had to
do a dance routine.
So I would just
stop, drop, and roll.
I would just do it on the spot.
Just so that I
could know I didn't
need to think about the dance.
And it was just all
about repetition.
So it was like cramming
for those days.
Completely.
Claire Hughes Johnson: You did
prepare, but it was intense.
DANICA PATRICK:
I mean, my calves
hurt from doing that
little dance so much.
It was only 17 seconds.
But it was long enough for my
calves to hurt for three days.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: You couldn't
get me to dance
for five seconds.
So good job.
DANICA PATRICK: But
it was great because I
was by far outside
of my comfort zone.
But it was really fun.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
That is great.
So a couple of final questions.
When you think about
all your balancing,
you're an entrepreneur, a
race car driver, obviously.
You've done things like this.
You've got your family that
you spend a lot of time with.
How do you balance all
those competing priorities?
Do you have a
framework in your head?
Or do you just take
it as it comes?
DANICA PATRICK: I think
you have to take some of it
as it comes because
sometimes it's new.
But for me it's definitely
been a little bit
of trial and error.
And as your life changes and
evolves, then gets bigger,
essentially I feel
like the older you get
there's more to
manage and balance.
And you just have to find
out what your own rhythm is.
How you like to
operate in your day?
prioritize things?
Do you like to bunch
your schedule up?
Do you like to spread it out?
Do you need to make
sure there's lunches?
I mean, down to all
those kinds of things.
Just, how do you
like to run your day?
And so I've figured
out what that is.
Now mind you, I mean
I was pretty exhausted
by the end of that
show in December.
And the rest of the stuff
I had to do in December.
But sometimes you
have to bend a little.
But you just can't get to
the point that you break.
If you break then that's
where the problems start.
And then it breaks
everything else down.
So it's OK to say no.
And as long as it comes from
a good, honest place of,
I'm not going to be
good for this situation
if I say yes, or good for
myself or good for my family,
then you just say no.
And you move on and know
that you're better for it.
And find those
little things that
make you happy along the way.
Whether it's going to get
a pedicure or massage.
For me, just sitting down
and playing Candy Crush.
Just whatever it is.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: Is
that on your mobile phone?
DANICA PATRICK: It is.
Ricky and I are always competing
against who's ahead of who.
I'm behind right now.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: So you
need to get over done with this
and do some Candy Crush.
And the final thing you
mentioned for your team,
that you focus a lot
on morale and being
someone who keeps
them motivated and up.
When you think about leadership
and being a role model, which
you said came to
you, you realized,
wow-- you are a role
model, by the way.
I have a colleague here
who brought her daughter
because her daughter
wrote a paper about you.
I think.
How do you carry
that responsibility?
What kind of leader are you?
How do you think
about being a leader?
How do you think about
being a role model?
Is that hard to have to
think about all the time?
DANICA PATRICK: I think that
it's about being yourself.
And then you can
really never screw up.
And I always encourage everyone,
whether they're young or old,
to do what you love to
do and be who you are.
And then you can't ever make
a mistake along the way.
You just are being who you are.
And if I get fiery and
intense at the racetrack,
I'm not shocking you.
I've done this before.
But that's who I am.
And if you don't like it at
least you can respect it.
So that's how I operate
in my days and my life.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
When did you realize that?
That you just have
to be who you are.
DANICA PATRICK: I think that
it just grows over time.
I think it's grown
over time to realize
that you can be
different and it's OK.
And that you can
have an opinion.
And in fact, I'm a
consumer, for sure.
And when I watch
things or people,
I don't just want to
watch people telling me
what I'm supposed to be hearing.
I want to see them be
honest and raw and real.
And maybe it sounds like
what I want to hear.
But maybe it doesn't.
And I respect them for that.
So I like people
to be who they are.
And the differences are
what make us interesting.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: All right.
Final thing.
It's a new year.
Any big goals for this year?
DANICA PATRICK: To be
the most Googled athlete.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON: I
think you already did that.
You already did that.
DANICA PATRICK: OK.
To be the most Googled
athlete at least today.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: All right.
I think you're already there.
DANICA PATRICK: No, I want
the whole one actually.
CLAIRE HUGHES JOHNSON:
You're all there.
But any races?
Anything?
Any race car driving thing?
I should ask.
DANICA PATRICK: I mean, it's my
second year in the Sprint Cup
Series.
It by no makes me
a veteran at all.
But for me it's
about progression.
And I don't think
that you can ever
know exactly where you should
be or what you should want.
And it's good to set goals.
For me I feel good to just
set progression goals.
And know that I'm
getting better.
And when I look back over
the last month, am I better?
Over the last six
months, am I better?
And of course my ultimate
goals are I want to win races.
I want to run in the top
15 as much as possible.
I want another Daytona 500 pole.
And I want to win
the whole race.
CLAIRE HUGHES
JOHNSON: All right.
Well, thank you so much.
This was great.
DANICA PATRICK: Thank you.
Thank you for coming everybody.